[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى اسبوع في العالم مشاهدينا
والذي نعود فيه كل يوم جمعه بتحرير ونقاش
الى ثلاثه مواضيع
ناقشناها طيله هذا الاسبوع المواضيع ثلاثه
من البدايه سنبدا بالحرب الاوكرانيه
والصواريخ التي سقطت في الاراضي البولنديه
كما سنعود ايضا بتحليل والنقاش لقمه
مجموعه ال20 في بالي وننهي بفتح موضوع
مونديال قطر الذي ينطلقوا هذا الاحاد
ونرحب بضيوفنا اذا لاسبوع في العالم اليوم
ابدا
بضيفتنا وزميلتنا من اذاعه مونت كارلو
الدوليه امل نادر اهلا وسهلا بك شكرا على
قبول دعواتك
وايضا معنا همم الصحفي والكاتبه السياسيه
فيصل جلوش شكرا على قبول الدعوه ومن برلين
ينضم الينا الكاتب والصحفي
برما ياسين مرحبا بك سيد شبرما ياسين نبدا
اذا بالموضوع الاول الحربه الاوكرانيه
مشاهدينا بحر هذا الاسبوع شهدنا الاتهامات
راشق الاتهامات والخشيه من اندلاع حرب
عالميه الثالثه بعد الاعلاني عن سقوطه
صواريخ هذه المره في الاراضي البولنديه
الدوله العضو في حلف شمال الاطلسي امل
نادر عندما همم
الدوليه وقرات هذا الخبر قولي لي بصراحه
هل قلت في ذلك انه يمكن ان نتقي في حرب
العالميه الثالثه اذا كان صحيح عن هذه
الصواريخ صواريخ روسيه
حلف شمال الاطلسي حلف الناتو يعني كل ضربه
ضد دوله عضو في هذا الحلف هي تعتبر ضربه
ضد كل الاعضاء الحلفاء يمكن الحلف ان
يتدخل وان يحمي هذه الدوله وهذا من واجب
الحلف همم طبعا انا الحدث خطير ولكن ااه
حقا عن لا لا شكيت بالامر لان همم ليس
بالامر السهل يعني ان تبدا حرب عالميه
لاني عندي قناعه داخليه انا لا احد يريد
حرب عالميه والتصريحات همم وردت وتوالت
هذا الاسبوع وقبل حتى يعني انه لا احد
يريد لا حرب عالميه ثالثه ولا حرب بارده
همم يعني طبعا الجميع يود ان يحصر الصراع
بين روسيا واوكرانيا وكما رايت طوال هذا
العام يعني الاتحاد الاوروبي دول اوروبيه
همم تساند اوكرانيا ولكن في نفس الوقت
تتخوف من خطوه همم ناقصه يعني خطوه تثير
الغضب الروسي يعني ربما حتى الروس ايضا لا
يريدون حرب عالميه ثالثه ولكن حكما ما جرى
وهذه همم الصواريخ التي همم وصلت داخل
الاراضي البولنديه
هي اا تحول خطير ونافت في هذه المعركه
وتدل ايضا على ان الصراع اليوم همم قد همم
يتسع نطاق هذا الصراع ليخرج عن السيطره
همم الروسيه الاوكرانيه
هذه هذا الصاروخ الذي سقط
همم كان اختبار لما قاله
جوبيدا من انه امريكا والحلف الاطلسي
مستعد للدفاع عن كل سنتيمتر في اي دوله
لها علاقه او عضو في الحلف الاطلس
هذا الاختباركن
على الرد الفوري
الكلام اللي حكيت ايضا لا ينجم عنه رد
فوري كما اشيع بعد همم بعد كلامه
همم
[موسيقى]
يمكن له ان يقدم على خطوه مثل هذا
بصاروخين او ثلاثه على الاراضي البولنديه
ويعلم جيدا انه يمكن ان يدخل العالم في
حرب العالميه الثالثه
الى ظرف اللي تم فيه ضرب الصاروخ كان في
قمه اساسيه
العشرين وسيم عنها موقف وقرار
الاولى انه
الروسي يريدون
وضع هذه القمه امام
خيار
هو الحرب الاردنيه
وباشباع كثيرين انه صاروخ جاء من اوكرانيا
وانه حتى لو كان الروس ضربوا التفسير اللي
على طول الامريكان وحلف الاطلسي انه هذا
الصاروخ جاء من اوكرانيا وبالتالي لا يوجد
نيه لدى الحلف الاطلسي
للرد الفوري
خوض الحرب مباشره لان الحلف الاطلس ياخذ
الحرب ضد روسيا عبر دعم
فقط كلمه صغيره لذلك الوحيد الذي مازال
يسر على انه الصاروخ روسي هو زينسكي
وزنسكي انا اعتقد ان لديه مصلحه في ذلك
لن يخرج منتصر
وهذا ما يراد له ان يخرج من الحرب الحرب
وصلت لمحل ما بقى معظم اللاعبين الدنيا
خطاب الرئيس الاوكراني التحول في الخطاب
يعني كيف في البدايه حين سقطوا الصاروخ
قال هو صاروخ روسي فيما بعد ابدى شكا في
ان يكون صاروخ روسيا وفيما بعد قال
الحقيقه لا ادري ماذا حصل اني اتطور هذا
الخطاب كان ملفت النظر وشاء ثاني انه همم
وتعقيبا على كلام استاذ فيصل انه اول من
دعى للحضر هو همم الجانب الامريكي وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي يعني اول من دعاه
مباشره
هذه القضاء
على كل همم يعني الحلف نيته لا يدخل
بالحرب مباشره لا يرد مباشره ليس الام
بهذه هي البساطه يعني لابد من اخذ ورد
وتداول والاخره يعني همم ياسين من برلين
تعتقد ان فلاديمير بوتين او روسيا يمكن
اللي بوتين مثلا ان يقدم على خطوه مثل هذا
ويستفز اكثر وهو يعلم انه يمكن ان يدخل
بلده في حرب عالميه
اهلا وسهلا
اريد حربا عالميه ثالث او ان روسيا تريد
الاقدام على ضرب اي دوله من دول حلف
الناتو لان روسيا تعلم ان هناك الماده
الرابعه والماده الخامسه التي يتم تفعيلها
ستقوم وسيقوم حلف الناتو بالدفاع الجميع
الدول الاعضاء اعتقد ان التسرع لدى الرئيس
الاوكراني بالربط هذا الصاروخ في الموقع
بالرؤوس
والرفض البولندي حتى ان بولندا رفضت ان
تكون ان يكون هذا التهام مباشره
في محله التسارع الاوروبي بجميع الدول
سارعت الى اتهام روسيا كان في غير محلي
حتى ان المسؤولين ابو همم قالوا ان الماء
ان المسؤولين الامريكيين وحتى بعض
المسؤولين البولنديين اخذوا هذه
الامتحان بصبر جميل وادركوا ان هذا
الصاروخ تم اطلاقه من اوكرانيا وهي من
مضادات
اسمع يعني الجميع لذلك لا يعتقد انه تريد
ان دخول حرب عالميه او دخول الحرب
من مصلحته ان يطلق هذه الصواريخ في همم
الاراضي البولنديه ويمكن ان يكون السبب في
اندلاع حرب كبيره في ذلك اليوم
صاروخ اطلقها الطائرات والسفن والغوصات
الصواريخ من قبل موسى على الاوكرانيه حتى
وصلت الى مدينه نجيب الاوكرانيه ولكن اس
300 وهي عباره عن
مضاد بالصواريخ هذه 300 اعتقد ان هناك
فساد في في المحتوى لهذا الصاروخ ما اجبره
على تحول مسار حتى ان المشكله من راي
العسكريين ان المشكله في قائد هذه
العمليات الصواريخ 300 الذي لم يستطيع
تدمير هذا الصاروخ في الاعلى بل اسقطه على
الاراضي البولنديه ومن هنا نجد الذين
لما بعد حتى خطاب ومن بعد النتائج الاوليه
التي خرجت ما زال يتهم روسيا بانها انا
صرت هذا في بولندا وما زال يريد ان دخول
النيته في حرب حتى يخفف من اللعب العسكري
لدى لدى شعبه نحن نعلم ان هناك مدن كثيره
في اوكرانيا الان ليس لديها الكهرباء ليس
لديها الماء وليس لديها التدفئه
امل نادر همم مثل ما قال سيد فيصل جلول
لناخذ كلام همم الرئيس الامريكي وايضا كل
قاده حلف شمال الاطلسي انهم سيردون في حال
ضربت او تم الاعتداء على دوله عضو في حلف
شمال الارناته هناك من يحقد مقارنات ما
بين تصرفات همم روسيا الان وما شهدته
البشريه في الحرب العالميه الثانيه
الحلفاء كانوا همم يصمتون ولم يتحركوا
عندما هتلر كان يقدم اقليم من الدول
المجاوره عندما اخذ اقليم لم يتحرك احد
وكانوا يدعون الى ضبط النفس ولا ندخل في
حرب العالميه ثالثه وهو كل مره يستفز اكثر
لانه يرى ان الطرف الاخر لن يرضع لانه
يخشى في الدخول في حرب عالميه
بولندا بولندا
في تلك الفتره كان هناك قاده بشجاعه
الكافيه رغم كل همم الماسي التي جاءت
تنجرت من الحرب العالميه الثانيه اعلن
الحرب على المانيا بوتين يمكن ان يتساقط
التصرف الان ولكن نحن نتعلم من التاريخ
يعتبرها همم يعني مكتسبه له او او هتلر
وتعرف هذا حلم الاتحاد السوفيتي السابق
ويحاول ان يقدم طبعا في المناطق التي هي
يعني قريبه منه وتشكل همم محاور
استراتيجيه ونقاط استراتيجيه بالنسبه له
وهو في يعني حين اخذ جزيره القرم همم لم
يتحرك احد وبالتالي بدا حينها يخطط لما
سيقوم به الان ولكن انا اعتقد انه همم
اليوم الظروف تختلف والمرحله تختلف ولا
احد يريد حربا عالميه همم هذا اولا ثم
اوروبا ضعيفه جدا يعني للدخول في حرب
الولايات المتحده بعيده واا يعني التعويل
عليها لست ادري ماذا يمكن ان يكون جديا
فبالتالي همم اعتقد ان الرئيس الروسي
اليوم يبد ان يخرج من الحرب منتصرا يعني
وهو
وحقق بعض الانتصارات همم التي يمكن ان همم
يعني يتحدث بها او ان تشعره بنوع من همم
عدم الخذلان همم ولكن لا يريد ان يدخل
بحرب عالميه همم تذكر انه منذ فتره منذ
اسابيع قليله ربما او ايام قليله حين
عدم عدم تحرك الغرب
لياخذوا الاقليم التي يريدها مثل ما شاء
الله
تحرك تحرك الغرب
ونندد بامكانيه همم قيام حرب نوويه همم
صرح بوتين بشكل واضح انه قال انا كنت ارد
على همم على الامريكيين ولكن انا لن
استخدم السلاح النووي وبالتالي هذا ايضا
له مؤشر بانه ولا يريد الدخول بحرب عالميه
لانه يعرف ان نتداعيات هذه الحرب على
روسيا وعلي وقد تكون يعني هي تثبتوني يعني
الدخول بحر ليس من الامر من الامر السهل
يعني
ولكن همم
المناطق التي تعد ممرات استراتيجيه
بالنسبه له اكيد هو سيحاول قدمها ويعني
قدمها بكل الاحوال سيحاول الحفاظ عليها
همم تحت السلطه الروسيه وهو يعرف ان يعني
رد وروسيا واوروبا لن ترد يعني وحتى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
عمل نادر الغرب لن يرد وشاهدنا همم قمه
مجموعه ال20 هو الموضوع الثاني الذي
يناقشه مشاهدينا الان كيف تحدث كثيرا عن
الحرب همم في اوكرانيا واثناء اجتماعيهم
سقطت هذه الصواريخ في بولندا وكانت هناك
اخر قصف مواقع
ومشاهده الطاقه في اوكرانيا هل يمكن ان
يتجرا بوتين ويقول ان الغرب لن همم يرد
ساصل كل سنه او سنتين اقدم جزءا اخر بدعوى
المجال الحيوي بدعوه ان هذه الاقاليم فيها
اقليه روسيه وعلى فكره نفس المصطلحات التي
كانت تستخدم من قبل النازيين في تلك
الفتره المجال الحيوي المانيا الاقاليم
التي يقطنها الناطقون باللغه الالمانيه
عندما ربح الغرب الحرب البارده
همم قربه مع الغربيين الدفاع انه الحلف
الاطلسي ما بيقرب على الحدود مع روسي
لم لم يتم احترام ذلك وقيل يومها بانه
الخاسر بالحرب لا يضع شروط خسرت الحرب بدك
تقبل
من بعد
بيت القمر اكثر تعقيدا
وصل الحال عند الروس لانه الشيشان شنو حرب
من الداخل ويتفكك روسيا نفسها شعر الروس
وبصوره خاصه قلب روسيا اذا بدك وبوتين
واحد منهم انه ااه هذا الامر يجب ان لا
يستمر قدم اربع طلبات للدخول الى الحلف
الاطلس
قدموا طلبات للدخول الحلف الاطلس رفض
الحلف الاطلسي ذلك
في هذه الحاله كان رد الفعل الروسي انه
نحن
نريد الدفاع عن الحدود بدا تتذكر
في المنطقه
الغربيه
بالموقع الروسي في العالم فقط
الحيوي مربوط بالمياه الدافئه
وانه ال الطريق اللي بيمر
بسبستوب بول
للدقيقه هو كانه روسيا مصير بالنسبه
القمر
[موسيقى]
عمليه عسكريه ضد سوريا
ضد سوريا وبالتالي الروس فاتته من على
الباب وشيله السلاح الكيماوي من سوريا
وكانت خدمه للجميع للغربيين ولا غير
للغربيه
لا ان اضتهم وبعد انه ما نتقدم للمحاكمه
بعدين المهم المهم
هذا الحال تخيل بلجيكا على حدود فرنسا
وقررت بلجيكا مثلا انه في اتفاق دولي
معمول مثل الاتفاق ميسك ميسك تلغيه وتحط
نظام الهدف تبعه تحدي روسيا روسيا اللي عم
تحاول تستعيد قوتها وتستعيد دورها الى
اخرها شو ممكن تعمل فرنسا او تخيل هناك مش
مثل اوكرانيا لكن تخيل دوله على حدود
فرنسا
لن
يعني تتردد فرنسا في الرد ورد بقوه اضيف
الى ذلك انه نحنا مستقل
حره
الاطلسي بقوه واستراتيجيه واستراتيجيه
الحفظ الاطلسي واحد وبالتالي حريه هذه
الدوله طيب لما تقولي هذه الدوله حره
كمان الدافئ
اخرى لا لا انا انا واعلان مناطق موجوده
من همم
الروسيه
لا احب الغزو لانه بلداننا محتله
وعرضه للحروب وبالتالي انا ضد الغسول لكن
في زيت الوقت وحاول انا افهم ما جرى
هنا تستطيع ان تشيطم فلاديمير بوتين من
وحتى وحتى نهايه التاريخ لكن انتبه له
ربحوا الروس الحرب ضد نابوليون بونابرت
موسكو بكامله
ربحوا الروس الحرب ضد النازي عبر ستالين
جراد وبالتالي الروس ما بيربحوا باطلاق
النار بالمدافع بالمعارك الاستراتيجيه
الروسي بيربحوا بي بي بي وضع كلمه بهذا
الامر والامريكي يعرف والغربيون يعرف
عندما اجتمعوا ما الذي قدم كحلل لايجاد
لايجاد حل لهذه القرار الذي صدر عن مجموعه
ال 20 ممتاز لانه هذا القرار يقول بانه
الحرب لن تحل مشكله في ااا بين اوكرانيا
وروسيا وبانه يجب الخروج من هذه الحرب هذا
قرار
لكن على على الارض ما الذي قدمته مجموعه
العايشين
مجموعه ال 20 هي اكبر اقتصاد اكبر قوه
بانه هذه المجموعه وصلت الى استنتاج بانه
السير بطريقه الحرب قد لا يكون لمصلحه
السيد
القمم وشهيدنا القمم عديده هذه الايام
كلها في شرق اسيا واخرها في بانكوك ما
الذي قدمته لانها بحثت كلها الحرب في
اوكرانيا
لم يصدر ادانا دي روسيا على حربها
لاوكرانيا كما ان المهم في هذه المجموعه
العشرين انهم اتفقوا على ان هذه الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا
الى الان هي اصبحت كارثه اقتصاديه على
العالم بشكل عام نحن نتحدث عن ارقام تضخم
كبيره وصلت الى 10 فاصل تسعه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي ناهيك على الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه نحن نتحدث عن دولت فقرا في
القاره الافريقيه في القاره الاسيويه
المجموعه ال 20 ارادت ان تمشي رساله الى
بلدهم يلبس ان الوضع الاقتصادي في العالم
جدا صعب وان الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
هي السبب الرئيس في هذا الوضع الاقتصادي
نحن نتحدث عن ازمه طاقه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي نحن نتحدث عن غلاء كبير في الدول
الاتحاد الاوروبي ذلك على الدول
نتحدث عن 35
الوقود
الغذاء كل هذه كل هذه جاءت نتائج لتلك
الحرب
وضعك بطلالها على مجموعه العشرين ما المهم
في مجموعه العشرين ايضا هذا التقارب
الامليكي الصيني الحذر الذي اضعه تحت خطين
الحدر لان الرئيس الامريكي بايدن جدد ان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه سياسه الصين
الواحده اي ان الصين
ولكن الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ترى ان
تايوان هي دوله مستقله وسيتم الدفاع عنها
وهو ما ادى الى ان الرئيس الصيني ايضا
يحضر الولايات المتحده الامريكيه من ان
ثاني وان هي تابعه للصين كلاب ذلك
المجموعه ال 20 ليس هي مجموعه تكرر اي
قرارات سياسيه هي مجموعه اقتصاديه فقط
والمهم ايضا فيما بعد ما بعد مجموعه اما
بعد قمه العشرين موافقه روسيا على امتداد
ايضا العالم بسنه الغذاء الموجوده في
اوكرانيا لمده ثلاثه اشهر لسنه حبوب
اعطاء اللي منها اذا كانت ال ال امر
الايجابيه فيها هي لقاءات الثنائيه لهذه
لهؤلاء الزعماء الذين يختلفون في ما بينهم
وشاهدنا الخلافات التي كانت واضحه بين
رئيس الصيني الذي كان حاضرا وخاصه بينه
وبين رئيس الوزراء الكندي
بروتوكاليه
يعني نوع الفلكلور ولكن ما يجري همم الى
جانب القمه هو الهم واللقاءات الثنائيه
اكيد وفي كواليسها همم ولكن اشوف يعني
تخيل انه كيف تريد ان تقدم قمه شيء مهم
وهي يعني يتم النقاش لايام وايام على كلمه
هل ندين همم الحرب هل نستخدم كلمه حرب او
لا نستخدم كلمه حرب يعني ليس هذا الاهم
ولكن هذه القمه في النهايه طبعا هي قمه
اقتصاديه وبحثت مساله امن الغذاء العالمي
الحرب الاوكرانيه اليوم هي مهمه جدا يعني
لتهدد الامن يعني الغذائي العالمي ومن بين
الاشياء اللي همم تمت خلال القمه وكان شيء
جيد كما ذكر زميل من برلين انه همم تمديد
اتفاق الحبوب يعني هو شيء قد تكون التهدئه
تمر عبر الغذاء لما لا يعني والشيء الاخر
همم الى جانب القمه همم
اللقاءات التي هتحصل بين مسؤولين كبار
مسؤولين الاستخبارات الامريكيه والروس من
جهه في تركيا واستخبارات الامريكيين
والاوكرانيين ايضا يعني قد نكون نتجه
باتجاه صفقه ما لي توصل الى تهدئه على كل
همم قمه مجموعه ال 20 اظهرت شيء مهم جدا
وهو الدور الصيني يعني الجميع يتحدث الى
الرئيس الصيني
لمحاوله الطلب منه همم تهدئه او يعني او
التوسط لدى همم الرئيس الروسي وبالتالي
نحن همم اليوم همم نشهد هذه في هذه
المرحله لا اريد ان اتحدث العوده الى
قطبين يعني عالميين الغرب والولايات
المتحده اوروبا من جهه والصين وروسيا من
جهه اخرى ولكن يعني وحديه
الموجوده
الدول الناشئه تفرض نفسها وتلعب دور
وتتكسر
من خلال هذه القمه قمه ال 20 همم او حتى
قمه ابك يعني تظهر نفسها على انها اليوم
لاعب اساسي وهمم مهم في في هذه يعني في
المرحله المقبله طيب هل تعتقدين ان
الاقتصاد وان هذه الازمه التي يعيشها
اللعالم بالازمه الاقتصاديه التضخم المال
همم الغذاء مشاكل في سلاسل توريد هي التي
ستدفع الى وقفه الحرب
يعني ليس بشكل مباشر اكيد ليست هي التي
ستدفع الى وقف الحرب بشكل مباشر وقف الحرب
يحتاج الى اتفاق الكبار يعني القاده
والزعماء وهناك لعبه مصالح وفي لعبه
المصالح الدوليه للعبه القوى الدوليه وشد
الحبال كل واحد يدافع عن مصالحه هذا الشيء
اكيد وكل واحد يدافع عن نظرته لموقعه في
العالم وفي الخارطه الجيوسيه هذا شيء اكيد
همم ولكن همم تجوع الشعوب اكيد هناك صرخه
لا يمكن التغاضي عنها وهي مؤشر مهم الروس
ايضا يعانون من هذه الازمه وهذا التضخم
جلول تعتقد ان نهايه هذه الحرب هو التواصل
الى اتفاق لوقتها بسبب هذا الضغط الكبير
من دول العالم من ارتفاع التضخم والمشاكل
الاقتصاديه التي تعانيها لانه همم السن
الماضي كان نسبه النمو سته بالمئه
وربما سن الجي اقل وهذا
اصلا في الدخول في مرحله الطاقه
عالميه بس انا اعتقد انه حرب عالميه
الحروب
العالميه الاولى ما كانت مثل الثانيه
والحرب اللي موجود مش مثل الثاني لذلك عن
نوع من الحروب
الخروج من الحرب ليس مساله اوكرانيه روسيه
الخروج من الحرب الهدف الابعد والعمق
الابعد له هو النظام العالمي الجديد
اعتقد سيكون متعدد الاخطاء حضرتك اشرت
ايضا الى الدور الصيني
والصين لعبه في هذه القمه دور اساسي ومهم
والتوازن الصيني الان كثير مهم ما سيجري
من بعد
ما ما فينا نقول انه هذه الحرب
وقع فيها خسائر غير مسبوقه فيها خسائر لكن
اذا طلع منه نظام عالم جديد يؤمن
الاستقرار ويكون متعدد الاقطاب بيكون فعلا
اقل الحروب ضررا ادت الى اكثر النتائج
ايجابيه على الصعيد
فيصل جلول اتمنى ان هذا ما سيحدث السيد
معك نصل الى الموضوع همم ثالث همم مونديال
قطر الذي اساء الحبر والجدل هل تعتقد ان
استضافت همم قطر هذه الدوله خليجيه
الصغيره همم حجما همم
[موسيقى]
سويس بشكل اكثر من اللازم قبل الصحافه
الفرنسيه الالمانيه الاوروبيه بشكل عام
عام
هي قطره صغيره حجما ولكنها كبيره بالموارد
كبيره بالافعال التي فعلتها
صحيح
[موسيقى]
الدول
الغربيه لديها اللغه الفوقيه لديها نظره
طبقيه عاليه نحو الدول اا غير الاوروبيه
او يغير على الامريكيه او غير التي تعيش
في شمال
الاستواء همم نحن نتحدث عن
فرنسا المانيا بريطانيا هذا الكم الهاء من
الكتابات الصحيه التي وضعتها في الخانه
الصفراء التي كانت خطر منذ حصودها على
تنظيم على تنظيم كاس العالم اعتقد ايضا ان
قطر ستنجح يوم الاحد القادم خلال هذا
العرس الكروييفي اظهار العالم في ما فعلته
قطر
السبب ان الدول الغربيه لا تريد النجاح
لقطها لا ترى في ان قطر اا دوله يمكن ان
ان ان
يوضع فيها كاس العالم
لماذا في رايك
تهاجم اذا كان اذا كانت هذه الدول تهاجمها
لاسباب اخرى غير الاسباب التي تتحدث عنها
الصحافه حقوق العماله الاجنبيه همم الحقوق
قضايا حقوق الانسان والحريات الفرديه
والعامه
نجحت في تبديل بعض الملفات الخاصه
بالعماله نحن هنا نرى ان قطر
مفهوم ما يعرف بالنظام الكفاله رفع الاجور
حريه التنقل للعمل
هناك قطر دوله اسلاميه دوله عربيه لا يحق
لها ان يكون لديها تنظيم كاس العالم
فعل نفس الشيء مع دول كوريا الجنوبيه
واليابان عندما نظمت كاس العالم ايضا
الفعل ذلك مع الجنوب افريقيا
الدول الاوروبيه
عندما صدفت روسيا عندما استضافت روسيا كاس
العالم الاخيره لم اقرا هذا همم عددا
كبيرا من المقالات على روسيا مثلا
صحيح هنا هناك وحتى نعترف بذلك ان روسيا
كانت احتلت شبه جزيره القرن في عام
انا اتحدث عن قطر انه من سيذهب اليه من
النجوم اللامعي الى قطر فهم فاهلا وسهلا
بهم لم يذهب الى قطر الامر سيان بالنسبه
لقطر النجاح
على حسب الدين
شبر مياسين في رايك اذا كانت همم مثل ما
قلت همم تشكك انت في المنظمات الحقوقيه
لماذا اذا تهاجم او تنتقد قطر ما السبب
اسباب اقتصاديه نحن نتحدث عن اسباب
اقتصاديه
بالعكس تستفيد من قطر تبيعها الاسلحه
تبيعها المواد
المنتجات الفاخره الفرنسيه
فرنسا تشارك بمعظم ال الفعاليات معظم
المباني التي تم بناءها في قطر فرنسا
تشارك فيها المانيا ايضا عندما هم كان
سبب هي حقوق الانسان
وظروف عمل العمال الاجانب لماذا اذا تنتقد
لديهم الحق في السفر في التنقل ما بين
عملي واخر كل هذه الاجراءات نجحت قطر
بفعل الضغوط التي مرثت عليها نجحت قطر
بوضع تشريعات جديده لحريه العمل ولقانون
اقتصاديه اسباب فوقيه وهناك الحقد اذا ما
اذا ماشينا نتحدث لماذا لا يحق لدوله
صغيره هم يتحدثون حتى على ان هذه الدوله
الصغيره
نحن نتحدث ايضا عن ان هذه المنديال قطر
وسبب وجوده في فصل الشتاء يمنع الكثير من
سيبدا الكثير من الخسائر الماديه لدى
القنوات التي تبث الالعاب الشتويه في
بريطانيا وفي فرنسا
لذلك ارى ان قطر ستنجح في هذا العرس
الكروي وهو مونديال لجميع العرب وليس
لدوله قطر منفرد شكرا ياسين امل نادر مرعي
يبكي في هذا الجدل لاول مره نقرا كل هذا
السيل من المقالات
مثلا البرازيل اا احتضنت المونديال كانت
هناك مظاهرات كبيره لم تشهد البرازيل
عندما احتضنت المونديال ايضا العاب
اولمبيه كانت في دول اخرى توصف
بدككتاتوريه وسلطه التركيز هذا الان هناك
هناك يقول انها حق اريد به باطل يعني هناك
اكيد يعني الكلام الذي يقوله همم
انه لا مش هي مش مساله حق دودين ولا اعتق
ذلك يعني اليوم هناك همم نوع في الغرب
يعني موضه او مش موضه يعني حقيقه توجه ما
همم بالنسبه مثلا لمساله هناك توجهات ما
وهناك مبادئ يدافعنا الغرب يعني من حيث
توجه يعني اليوم قضايا البيئه
انا عنوان عريض الصحافه الغربيه تدافع
عنهم
[موسيقى]
مساله حقوق الانسانيه وحده احدى القضايا
التي يدافع عنها الغرب دائما يعني كان
الصحافه الغربيه او كان يعني على المستوى
السياسي والى اخره او الجمعيات والجمعيات
حقوق الانسان ان كان هناك ماخذ على بعض او
ليس هناك اخذ يعني هناك ارقام حقيقيه يعني
عدد من الناس الذين العمال الذين قتلوا
همم تردد صحتهم الى اخره همم
ظروف العمل وظروف همم بناء كل هذه
المجمعات التي بنيت بوقت همم يعني قياسي
اكيد انه لم يحترم فيها شروط الغربيه
فلنقل همم في العلاء العماله وقوانين
العمل والى اخره فهي اكيد موضع نقد هلا
المشكل انا الذي يلفت نظري انه لماذا الان
يعني قطر همم المساله عمرها 10 سنوات كان
يمكن انتقاد قبل الان
قطعا ولكن الان بشكل كبير يعني
في البدايه وليس الان وما حققته قطر يعني
الصوره التي سنراها الاحد اكيد ستكون صوره
جميله ومبهره
ثار ولا الناظر والمشارك والاخره ولكن لا
يمكن ان ننتقد في النهايه من يدافع عن
حقوق الانسان اقول لك لماذا لان هذه
المناسبات كان القمه مثلا شوف قمه شرم
الشيخ مثلا عن المناخ همم الدفاع عن حقوق
الانسان كان فيها تصدر يعني المشهد وتخطى
مساله البيئه اذا هذه المناسبات يعني تحشد
همم كم هائل من المشاركين من الاعلام من
الصحفيين من اللاعبين الى اخره حكما هي
مناسبه
للمدافعين عن حقوق الانسان له تسليط او
حتى لوسائل الاعلام لتسليط الضوء على
قضايا من هذا النوع لان لا يكون هناك
مناسبه اخرى توازي هذه المناسبه لتصيب
الضوء عليها اذا كانت هناك دوله اخرى
مثلا دول الخليجيه لنا قريبه من قطر حول
الحقوق ولو ان هناك فرقات بسيطه الى مثلا
استضافه المواضيع هل ستنتقد بنفس لا دائما
تنتقد دائما تنتقد مصر انتقد الدول
الخليجيه تنطق كل الدول تنطق يعني الاعلام
الغربي ينتقد الدول
عندما تنظم مستقبلا المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
العاب الشتويه
مطروحه وهذه مناسبات
مساله المناخ مساله اخرى يعني كل دوله يحق
لها ان همم ان تامن الشروط وان تقيم يعني
مناسبات اركان رياضيه هناك شيء مهم يعني
اود اختم به رفيق هذه تعليق يعني انه قطر
بالنهايه تستخدم القوه الناعمه وهي
يعني وهي من اهم من استخدم القوه النائمه
من حيث الاعلام
اذا همم يعني همم تدخل في اللعبه يعني
الصراع العربي العربي العربي منذ عام 2010
وهناك دول همم تريد ان تقود المنطقه
العربيه خلافات عربيه عربيه وصلت الى ال-
الخلاف بين قطر ودول العربيه والى همم
سميه بالحصار ما سميه بالمقاطعه والدول
تريد هي ان تكون لها تاثير والقوى الناعمه
سواء قطر او الامارات العربيه المتحده او
المملكه العربيه السعوديه او مصر السيد
فيصل جلول كيف نضع المونديال في اطار
الحسابات العربيه العربيه
ااااه بدايه اسمح لي فقط في نقطه
قطر اعترفت انه في انتهاك لحقوق الانسان
بالنسبه للبناء
الخلاف بينه وبين الغربيين هو حول الحجم
قطر
الموجوده
معترف فيها من الطرفين وبالتالي لا يمكن
القول انه ما في مشكله
ثانيه قصه المثليين مثلا
بالنسبه للقطر لا تريد همم هذه الظاهره ان
تكون مرافقه لكاس العالم الغربيين يعتقدون
لانه هذه همم واحده من قيامهم
لاصبحت قيم عالميه وانه لا يجوز ان تعاقب
بالحبسه الحريات الحريه
لان يدخل في النطاق الحريات الفرديه
والحريات العامه هل هل هذا المشكل ينسحب
على كل دول العالم العربيه
حتى الاسلاميه ايضا في دوله اسلاميه تجئيس
سؤال
تنظم كاس العالم
ولا دوله تذكر لي دوله كانت تريد ان تنظم
خطر وبصوره خاصه دول الخليج
اربع سنوات اربع سنوات اربع سنوات
[موسيقى]
انا اقول بانه الدول الخليجيه اربع سنوات
محاصره قطر حتى كان في مشروع لانه يعزلوا
قطر عن البر يحاولوها لجزيره وبالتالي
وبالتالي
التي حصلتها اوقاتها ان همم تشاركها في
تنظيم المباراه
القوه
ايضا قطر صغيره
عندما مشاكل تقريبا مع معظم دول حولها
وبالتالي
تريد ان تلعب دور وعند الحق عند ااا ثاني
مصدر للثاني احتياط غاز بالعالم ثاني عند
موقع استراتيجي عند
حجما
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ما بيخلي مناسبه من هذا النوع تمر بدون ما
ينجم عنها مشاكل
همم الان فقط
هل يحق لي قطر
ان تنظم كاس العالم بشروطها ام بشروط
العالم
انا اظن بانه يمكن مزاوجه الشرطين يمكن
احترام التعدديه على الصعيد العالمي
فوارق ثقافيه الدوله
[موسيقى]
ناعمه
البرنامج لاول مره دوله عربيه تستضيف
المونديال وكنا نحلم بهذا او لم نكن نصدق
ان دوله عربيه ستستضيفها المونديال هل
يمكن يوما ما فريق عربي يفوز بكاس العالم
يفوز انا اتوقع ان تفوز فرنسا ثانيا
خلينا نقول فرنسا
[موسيقى]